(dramatic instrumental music)
- [Narrator] March 1963,
the CIA is planning
to kill Fidel Castro using
his greatest guilty pleasure:
a milkshake.
(slurping)
- [Man] Mm.
- [Narrator] The U.S. feared
Castro's anti-American views,
and according to Castro's bodyguard,
the CIA plotted 638 times to sabotage him
trying things like chemical
powder on his boots,
a bacterial-lined scuba
suit, spiked cigars,
and exploding cigars.
But, the closest the CIA
came to killing Castro?
Poisoning his chocolate milkshake
at his favorite ice cream parlor.
The dictator had an obsession with dairy,
ice cream, milkshakes, you name it.
I mean, it gets hot in Cuba.
So, the CIA convinced mafia members
to carry out the plot.
The mobsters delivered
a pill containing poison
to a waiter who would slipped the capsule
into Castro's milkshake.
The waiter placed the pill in the freezer
until the time was right,
but the pill froze to the freezer's lining
and when he went to pick
it up, the pill ripped open
spilling poison everywhere.
So, the would-be assassin
waiter abandoned the plot.
The mission was a bust.
Castro went on to become one
of the world's longest ruling leaders,
arrogantly boasting, "If
surviving assassination attempts
"were an Olympic event, I
would win the gold medal."